- It has a sweetness.
It's not like it's a dessert.
- Right.
- It's a savory meal.
- Yeah.
- But it's quite sweet.
- Like on a hot summer
day, this would be amazing.
(upbeat music)
- We are in Korea Town in
Los Angeles, at Mimimyunga,
to try the best soba from Korea.
It was featured in
Michelin Guide from Korea,
and they are doing really,
really, really, really good.
- Oh, so it's like a restaurant chain?
- Right, right, yeah.
- Oh, cool.
- Soba's originally from
Japanese, but this restaurant
is from Korea.
- The main thing that makes it stand out
is that it can be served cold.
- They also serve warm soba here.
- Usually noodles, you
know, you have it in broth,
but this one you have it separate,
and you can dip it in the broth.
- I like sweet noodles, I don't know why.
I don't like sweet drinks,
but I like sweet dishes.
- It was sugary?
- It's kind of sweet.
- This is much different than I expected.
This plating though,
it reminds me a little bit
of ramen in the presentation.
- It does, I looks like
ramen but it's weird.
- But it's cold.
- Cause like, when you
feel the bowl it's cold.
- It's real cold.
- Should we start eating?
- Oops.
- So good.
It's so good.
- It's so good.
- It's really good with the wasabi.
I do taste the sweetness.
- Right?
It is sweet, yeah.
- Yeah, there is some sweetness there.
- The broth is like, really steamed.
When they make the
broth, it takes 24 hours.
- For this broth?
- Yeah.
- Wow.
- Whoa.
- And also, the noodles
soak in the broth so well,
so you can taste it really well.
- Yeah, yeah.
You guys never tried an uni before, right?
This is uni.
- This is uni?
- Mmmhmmm, sea urchin.
But I don't know if you'll like it or not,
because it's very fishy.
- Mmmm, it's very fishy but it's good.
What do you think Wy Beem?
(laughing)
- It's not for me.
- It's hot.
- I love hot.
- And the noodles are
still the soba noodles?
- Yeah, but wheat noodles.
- Oh.
- I've never had soba
noddles inside a hot broth.
- It's good.
- It's good, right?
- I can taste like, a mushroom flavor.
- Oh, yeah.
(coughing)
So spicy.
- You okay?
Yeah, sweetness is not as much there,
but there's like a hint of it.
- Yeah, it's more savory.
- It's definitely more savory.
- This beef is so good.
- Beef is so good.
- Yeah, beef is so good.
- The egg is good, again.
- Yeah, look how they cook the egg.
- I heard from Japanese chef,
the better you cook the soft
boiled egg, the better restaurant it is.
So they have to cook the egg perfect,
this is perfect soft boiled egg.
- It's really perfect.
- Yeah.
This is warm soba we just had,
with, is it seasoned mackerel?
- It's boneless?
- Is it?
- They just said boneless.
- My boneless.
- How do you make it boneless?
- You take the bones out.
- But how do you take...
- How?
(laughing)
- We laugh.
- The fish is good, the seasoning's nice.
- Wow.
- It's really well prepared,
it goes together really nicely.
- Yeah.
- I like the kimchi too.
- Oh.
- Right?
- Yeah, it tastes different.
- It's cabbage kimchi, cabbage.
- It tastes a little sweeter.
- It's sweet, yeah.
- The broth and everything
is pretty much the same.
I think the difference
is the fishy flavor,
verses a beefy flavor.
- I almost finishing everything now.
This is so easy to eat.
- I'm incredibly full,
which means that the meal was successful.
It was so good.
- Me too, yeah, my favorite.
- I think I'd be on team hot noodle.
But that might be just
because I'm a hot noodle gal.
But, I will say,
that if you hadn't tried
cold noodles before,
this is incredibly good and
definitely would leave you
full and wanting to finish the
whole thing, it was so tasty.